COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER-
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. FRAZIER FONG.
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN. TO
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DE. FRIEDMAN
GIPSON HERE. GRAYSON KILEY.
MEDINA NAZARIAN. O'DONNELL
JERRY OF A QUORUM. WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO I'D LIKE TO GO OVER A
LITTLE BIT OF THE LOGISTICS FOR
THE MEETING TODAY. TO START I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAFF THAT HAVE MADE POSSIBLE
RETURN TO THE CAPITAL TO HEAR
BILLS. THIS INCLUDES STAFF FROMASSEMBLY RULES. THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS AND THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER WHO PUT IN COUNCIL
COUNTLESS HOURS. SECURING AND
CONFIGURING THE NEW EQUIPMENT
AND TECHNOLOGY. WE'RE ABLE TO
USE TODAY TO MAXIMIZE OUR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTICIPATION
OR HILLS. WE'LL TAKE A
MOMENTARY PAUSE.
SO I'D LIKE TO
START. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE STAFF OF MADE POSSIBLE
RETURNS THE CAPITAL HERE BILLS.
THIS INCLUDES STAFF FROM THE
ASSEMBLY RULES SIMPLY SERGEANTS
AND THE LEGISLATIVE DATA
CENTER- PUTTING COUNTLESS HOURS
PROCURING CONFIGURING THE NEW
EQUIPMENT AND TECHNOLOGY. WERE
ABLE TO USE TODAY TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTICIPATION. IN OUR HEARINGS.
TO THAT END I WILL NOW SHARE A
FEW NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
OF OUR HEARING TODAY. DUE TO
THE CURRENT STATE HOME ORDER.
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER.
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. TODAY ANY
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WE'RE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY- DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ONLY A COMEDY FIFTEEN MEMBERS.
A MINUTE MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF AT A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PUBLIC AND MEDIA IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. WITH ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE WHEN APPROPRIATE. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC WILL
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE FISCAL
DISTANCING BEFORE LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING WOMEN TING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AN ACCESS
CODE IS TWO FOUR. TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON THE
HEARING VIDEO FEED. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THE- BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
A BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN LOCKED ON A LIVE LINE
AND YOU WILL NEED TO PLEASE
MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED UPON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROP THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
THREE AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY T. I
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
EMPLOYMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. MEMBERS PLEASE NOTE THAT
THE MIKE'S HERE IN THE CHAMBER
TURN ON WHEN THEY'RE RAISED. SO
IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO A ROLL
CALL OR ASK A QUESTION OR
PROVIDE A COMMON. YOU WILL NEED
TO RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE.
PLEASE ALSO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE IF YOU ARE SPEAKING.
RECOGNITION TO ASK A QUESTION
OR MAKE A COMMENT. AS IT WILL
HELP STAFF BETTER CONTROL THE
SOUND QUE CONSUL. IT WOULD BE
GREAT IF YOU ALSO STAND UP
WHILE SPEAKING TO ENSURE YOUR
VOICE AUDIBLE AND CAN BE
RECORDED. LET'S ALL TRY TO BE
PATIENT AND ROLL WITH IT TODAY.
I WILL BE FINE. OKAY NOW THAT
WE'VE COVERED THAT. AND ALL OF
THAT LET'S MOVE ON. MOVE
FORWARD TO AB. THREE THREE TWO
ONE THREE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIP
OFFS. RIGHT. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WELL WHAT A HISTORIC
MOMENT- THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING TODAY I THINK I'M
ONE OF THE FIRST MEMBERS TO
PRESENT A BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS BUT THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND FOR EVERYONE
THAT MADE THIS POSSIBLE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT. AB THREE TWO
ONE THREE. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
TO PRIORITIZE PROJECTS WHICH
PROVIDE THE MOST OVERALL
BENEFIT TO THE STATE. INCREASED
PASSENGER RAIL RIDERSHIP. AND
EFFECTIVELY REPLACE AUTOMOBILE
TRIPS WITH PASSENGER RAIL
TRACKS. AT THIS POINT I'D LIKE
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT MY INTENT. I
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
ABANDON THE BILLIONS IN
INVESTMENTS THAT THE STATE HAS
ALREADY SPENT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. HOWEVER I DO BELIEVE WE
HAVE A FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
TO THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
BEFORE COMPELLING THIS
LEGISLATURE TO INCUR
SIGNIFICANT ELECTRIFICATION
COSTS WE MUST CONSIDER IF THE
PORTION OF THOSE FUNDS COULD
OTHERWISE BE REDIRECTED. TO
INCREASING STATEWIDE RAIL
RIDERSHIP. I SHOULD ALSO
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN WHAT CAUSED ME
TO INTRODUCE THIS BILL IN THE
FIRST PLACE. LAST YEAR AS A
MEMBER OF ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION. I
RECEIVED AN UPDATE ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT FROM THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. I
ASKED WHY DID MAY NOT INCLUDE A
SINGLE ALTERNATIVE IN THEIR
PROJECT UPDATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER I ASKED
WHY THE ONLY OPTION THEY WERE
PRESENTING WAS ONE TO
CONTINUOUS ELECTRIFY THE LINE
FOR MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD I
WENT ON TO EXPLAIN THAT I WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO SEE VARIOUS
OPTIONS. IN THIS PROJECT UPDATE.
THE AUTHORITY RESPONDED DURING
THE HEARING THAT THERE TWENTY
NINETEEN UPDATE WAS BASED OFF
OF COMMITMENTS MADE. IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN
TO LOOK AT THE VALLEY TO VALLEY
PORTION. DESPITE MY INPUT THE
H. A SORRY FAILED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THOSE REQUEST
RAISED. IN TWENTY NINETEEN AS
THEY PREPARED AN ISSUE THERE
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN. I
NEVER ONCE HEARD FROM THEM AND
IT'S PRETTY EASY TO FIND MY
OFFICE. AS A RESULT I
INTRODUCED AB THIRTY TWO ONE
TWO TO ENSURE WE GET ANSWERS TO
THOSE OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF REVERSE DO
YOU HAVE ANY MEMBERS AND OF THE
PUBLIC THE LIKE A TEST FINDS
FORTY BILL. NO. THE SECOND
TWENTY MOVE THE BILL THANK THE
AUTHOR. ON MOTION BY- SO MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. MR. GIPSON THIS IS A
SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION. SO YOU
HAVE NO. NO OFFICE NO THAT'S TO
THE CORRECT. IN THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SING NINE. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THREE NINE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE OFFICE. WITH A. ON THE
PHONE WITH THE CALLING IN- TO
TEST BY THE WAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT. PHONE MISTER SECRETARY.
US WILL GO FORWARD WITH MY
COMMENTS AND HAVE YOU TAKE THE
ROLE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL AS
YOU KNOW I HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
AT THE THIRTIES MOVING FORWARD
WITH A PLAN. THAT IS NOT WHAT
IS BEST FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THEY THINK IS
BEST IS ONLY FOR THEIR PROJECT.
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT BEEN
INCLUDED IN THIS PROJECT FROM
THE START BUT DESPITE FUNDING
NEARLY ALL OF IT TO THIS POINT.
IT'S TIME WE START PUTTING
INSTEAD TO WHAT WE EXPECT FROM
THE AUTHORITY SO THEY PAY
ATTENTION TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND WITH THAT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
SEPARATELY CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- MISTER FRAZIER.
FRAZIER HI PAUL. FONG HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN. BERMAN HI TO. TWO HI
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DALY I DEEP. DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON I
GRAYSON. GRAYSON I KILEY KILEY
I MEDINA. MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
HI. FIFTEEN VOTER. THE BILL
FIFTEEN- WITHOUT GRADUATIONS-
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
A THOROUGH ANALYSIS- THANK YOU
TO ALL THE MEMBERS REPORTER
YOUR SUCCESS ON THE BILL. WILL
MOVE FOR NOW TO- AB THREE THREE
TWO SEVEN SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO START OFF BY WISHING TO
CHAIR AM I SEE MADE HAPPY
BIRTHDAY I WOULD HAVE SEND YOU
HAPPY BIRTHDAY BUT SOMEONE ELSE
ALREADY DID IT AND I DO WANNA
LOSE ANY VOTES. I COME BEFORE
YOU TODAY TO PRESENT AB THREE
THIRTY TO SEVENTY SEVEN THE
BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS FACING PARKING
FINES CURRENT LAW ALLOWS FOR
PAYMENT PLANS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH UP TO THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN PARKING TICKETS AND
THIS BILL SIMPLY INCREASES THE
TICKET CAP TO SEVEN FIFTY
DOLLARS.TO PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS
MORE TIME TO PAY AND THREE
PROVIDES MORE TIME FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO ROLL IN A
PAYMENT PLAN. FOR THIS PANDEMIC
INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGHER PARKING
DEBT WE'RE AT RISK OF BEING
DEBT BURDEN AND HAD TO CHOOSE
TO PAY FOR THE HOUSING OR
PARKING TICKETS. HOWEVER DURING
HIS CURRENT HEALTH CRISIS
INDIVIDUALS FACE EVEN MORE OF
THOSE CHOICES. AND THEY DO SO
WITHOUT EARNING AN INCOME
DURING THE SAME DURING THE STAY
AT HOME BORDERS. WHEN THIS
CRISIS IS OVER AND PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO EARN AN INCOME. THEY
WILL NEED TO DECIDE- PAPERS
THEIR LANDLORD THE BANK FOR
CITIES. THIS STEP WILL EASE THE
BURDEN THAT PURPOSE BY
PROVIDING INDIVIDUALS WERE
HIGHER PARKING GET ACCESS TO A
PAYMENT PLAN. FOR THE MORE BY
ALLOWING MORE ACCESS TO PAYMENT
PLAN CITIES WILL BE ABLE TO
COLLECT MORE REVENUE. WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AT A TIME
WHEN LOCALITIES ARE FACING
BUDGET SHORTFALLS. AB THIRTY
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SPONSORED BY A DIVERSE GROUP OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. ACLU THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE CURRENT SHOW
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. THIS BILL
WILL OFFER IMPORTANT ECONOMIC
RELIEF WHILE PROVIDING CITIES A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE WAY TO
COLLECT REVENUES THAT ENDED
INDIVIDUALS. WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ON ABLE TO PAY. ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY TRACY
PRODIGY FROM LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. ENGINE
NAY WALK INS FROM PAST LA.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE A COUPLE. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON THE PHONE. TRACY ARE
YOU THERE. I'M HERE YES I'M
HERE. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
TERRY FRAZIER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
MY NAME IS TREATED HOW DO KEY
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY THE LEAD
ADMINISTRATOR OF HOMELESS
SERVICES IN THE LOS ANGELES GM
CARE AND WE'RE HERE TODAY AT
OUT ONTO THAT THE CELL. AND
TWENTY NINETEEN THERE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ON A
GIVEN NIGHT AT PERCENT OCCUR
ARE AND LIVING ON A SIDEWALK.
INTENT OUR AND ARE THESE STATE
WIDE. IN LOS ANGELES ON JUST
OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE WITHIN THEIR
VEHICLES EACH NIGHT. A VEHICLE
PROVIDE THE LAST VESTIGES
STABILITY AND SAFETY COMPARED
WITH THE THING ON THE STREET.
AND THIRD WITH THE LIFELINE
CONFINEMENT OR MEDICAL CARE AND
OTHER SERVICES BUT THE POINT OF
PRE. TRANSITION BACK INTO HOW
THE ABILITY. SHELTERING AN IDEA
OF. COOLEY MODERATE THE HIGH
WITH A PARKING CITATION AND
VEHICLE LAW. GIVING THEM OF
THEIR MOST IMPORTANT OUT THAT
AND POTENTIAL PATHWAYS ACTING
HOMELESSNESS. OUR HOME A CRISIS
IS JUST ONE PIECE OF A LARGER
CRISIS AND MANY MORE HEALTH
WILL BE CLINGING TO THEIR
pHOUSING. THE END OF COUNTY IS
HOME TO OVER HALF A MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS ANY 50% OR MORE OF
THEIR EARNINGS ON HOUSING
LEAVING LITTLE FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AGAINST UNEXPECTED
EXPENSES INCLUDING PARKING
PENALTY. BUT THE COVER CRISIS
NOW SHIPPING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS OF THEIR INCOME WE
NEED TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY FOR
HELPFUL. ALL RIGHT THAT THAT.
ENSURE THAT ANY SENTENCE DON'T
PUSH THEM INTO HOMELESSNESS ONE
FISCAL CRISIS THAT. WE GIVE ME
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS OF
POSSIBLE AND REASONABLE
ARRANGEMENT RESULT THEIR
PARKING THAT. THIS AB THREE TO
SEVEN SEVEN CONTINUES TO
ENHANCE THE PREPAYMENT OPTION
THANK THANK YOU CAN EXPECT
ABILITY MOTOR AT THE HIGHER
LEVEL OF THE PARKING THAT.
EXTENDING THE APPLICATION THAT
LINE AND LENGTHENING THE PAY
BACK PERIOD ALLOW PARTICIPANTS
MORE TIME TO COMPLETE THEIR
PLAN. YEAH APPRECIATE IMPORTANT
ROLE OF CITIES IN THE
CONVERSATION AND THEIR NEED TO
MAINTAIN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OTHER NEIGHBORHOODS AND FOURTH
PARKING WILL. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING TOGETHER AND IF YOU
HAD TO DRESS THEIR CONCERN-
CONTINUING TO ADVANCE OUR GOAL
OF REDUCING BARRIERS. FACT THAT
PROMOTES VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. WHO ARE THE
MODERATOR IF THE JUNE A WHAT'S
IS ON THE PHONE. YES I AM SURE
THEY WOULD YOU PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND- YOU'RE
REPRESENTING PLEASE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE TRANSPORTATION THE
LINING OF CHEN NAY BLOCK AND I
LOOK FOR A PATH IN THE HOME.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. BECAUSE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE ANY. HELLO HI I ALSO
HANDED MY CONCERN. IF MICHAEL.
NO NO I'M SORRY I THOUGHT I
LOST YOU AS WELL- I AM ACTUALLY
IN FAVOR OF AB FOR THE TWO OF
THEM AND THE CAPACITY OF
WORKING FOR PASSED BY AND- WHEN
SUCH LOOK LIKE WE WORK WITH
FAMILIES BY BEING HAS THE
POWER. USUALLY SINGLE MOTHERS
BUT- IT'S ALL. A AMOUNT BLOOD.
ONE MINUTE THAT I TRY. THE
VARIOUS PROBLEMS THAT OKAY IS
THE PHONE THE ARE ONE OF THOSE.
NUMBER. TWO ONE SIX CALL THEIR
ABILITY. FIVE OUT OF. OUR
FAMILIES ARE MORE OF THEM MORE
AND OR UNDER ROOM AND THE
SPECIAL INSTEAD OF CURRENTLY
MAKES IF YOU BOUGHT WHILE WE
LEAVING UBER NO WAGE DEFENSE
THOUGH AN AVERAGE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH HOW OLD WERE
WITH THANK. THE PARKS HARDSHIPS
WHAT THEM. IT I ALSO WORK LOCAL
REYES AND MANY OF THE WORK THE
AGENCY ONE ALONG OF OUR CLIENTS
WHICH OPPORTUNITY ARE OTHER OF
OFFER THAT WE HAVE WAY AND
FINANCE WITH THE- ABILITY.
HOWEVER MAY JOB MOST. HIGHER
INDIVIDUALS YEAH LED BY LIKE
AND THEIR OWN OF ANY OF CLEAR
UP A TO REQUIRE ONE OF HELP A
CAR THE VERY OLD I HAVE A CAR
OR A THAT SO IS. BEING BELL WE
GET ONE PLACE LINE. IN A
PERFECT WORLD MANY MORE YOU THE
ISSUE AS JUST PAYING A PARKING
TICKET BUT IT'S MORE THAT. IF
YOU REALLY A DOM EFFECT THAT
BEGIN AND BUT ALL A RATHER HOLE
IN LET ME FINANCIAL BIRD.
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF FUN. THE
BILL OF BIG FISH THAT ARE. YOUR
SINCE ONE POINT THAT FINDING
THE BILL WOULD BE I OUT BUT YOU
WERE AB THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
THANK YOU CHARLIE AND- HELLO
THANK YOU. MOM THANK YOU FOR.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AS TO OF
THE AUTHOR BILL. THING NINE.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
COLLECTED. OPPOSITION OF THE.
THROUGH THE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN. SUPPORT
OF THE OFFICE OF. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN FOR THOSE OF YOU ON
THE PHONE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. TO BE JUST A MOMENT. WE
DO HAVE A QUESTION OR A COMMENT
FROM THE LINE OF MIA INGRAM.
PLEASE GO AHEAD CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. WE MISSED THE FIRST
PART OF THAT MAN WE HAVE YOU
REPEAT IT. MY AIM BROWN ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THROUGH
THE MODERATOR IS THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC STILL
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. WE STILL HAVE A FEW-
THAT ARE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT WE
DO HAVE- SURELY HE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS SURELY NEED
WITH MY PATH IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. STILL HAVE A FEW
MORE MEMBERS IN SUPPORT ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE- COMMENT FROM
MIKE HERALD PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT MY CURLED
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE LAST NINE IN
SUPPORT ONE MOMENT. AND ANDREW
AND TO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH
IS A NUMBER THANK YOU ALL FORTY
DOING TODAY COMING BACK TO DO
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS AND
YOU'RE ACTUALLY HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE NOT ADOPTED A FORMAL
POSITION GET ON THE BILL WE NAY
CLEANER WORK WITH AUTHOR STATUS
BUT WE THINK WE ARE. PROPOSAL
AN OUR CITY TO. INSPIRED NEARED
PROGRAMS LIKE ME LEVINE
ASSISTANCE FOR THE INDIGENT
BINDING SPELLS WITH BACK
PARKING LOT WILL REPORT TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL PROGRESSIVE. AND AT THIS
TIME THOSE IN OPPOSITION. OF
THE BILL MAY HAVE YOU PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY COMMENTARY. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THE
MODERATOR. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. SEEING NONE MISTER
JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
WILL CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND PLAN TO WORK
WITH THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
MOVEMENT BY MISTER HOLD GRAYSON
SECOND BY MR GIPSON AGAIN.
MISTER JONES SAWYER HOBBIES FOR
YOUR BILL THE DAY IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO TAKE ACTIONS THAT TIME TO
ASSIST THOSE LIVING IN POVERTY
AND I COMMEND YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL.
STE MR SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- CHAIR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I FONG LONG HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY HI
BERMAN BERMAN HI TO. TWO I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DALY I DEEP. DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GIPSON I
GRAYSON. GRAYSON I KILEY. KILEY
I MEDINA MEDINA HI MS ARIAN.
NAZARIAN I O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL
HI. IT'S FIFTEEN VOTES ARE. THE
BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES IT
MEASURES OUT THANK YOU CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT FILE. HI
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THERE'S
A CONSENT. NUMBER ONE AB TWO
TWO ZERO ZERO ZERO SIX FONG.
NUMBER TWO TWO A. B. TWO ZERO
THREE EIGHT TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY ONE MATHIS
NUMBER FOUR AB TWELVE ONE
SEVENTY TWO PETRIE-NORRIS
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. NUMBER SIX EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO KALRA.
NUMBER TEN. ACR ONE THIRTY NINE
ARAMBULA NUMBER ELEVEN ACR ONE
FORTY SEVEN LACKEY NUMBER
TWELVE IS YOUR ONE SIXTY FIVE
TING NUMBER THIRTEEN A C. R.
SIXTY SEVEN OR TO LETTER NUMBER
FOURTEEN AS YOUR- STATE
ARCHULETA TO. HAVE A FIRST BY
IS SINCE SECOND MISTER FONG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FOR THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER FRAZIER.
FRAZIER HI FONG. FONG HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY HI
BERMAN. BERMAN HI. TO TWO HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI DALY
DALY I DEEP. DEEP I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GIPSON I
GRAYSON GRAYSON I KILEY KILEY
HI MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
MARION O'DONNELL O'DONNELL HI
DEAN VOTE. CONSENT CALENDARS
FIFTEEN- IT MOVES OUT. LET'S
MOVE ON TO- AB TWO THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT MISTER PATTERSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR THANK YOU
PLEASE START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. AT CHAIR MEMBERS.
THIS BILL REITERATES THE WILL
OF THE VOTERS IN PASSING
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN STATING
THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
SHALL NOT REQUIRED OPERATING
SUBSIDY. THIS YEAR DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN FROM THE
AUTHORITY MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
THE INITIAL SEGMENT CANNOT
OPERATE WITHOUT A STATE SUB A
SUBSIDY. AND THAT'S CURRENTLY
ESTIMATED COST FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. THE
PLAN ALSO MAKES IT OBVIOUS THAT
THE AUTHORITY BELIEVES ERODING
ASSEMBLY- THAT IT DOES NOT
VIOLATE PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY
BECAUSE AN EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR. WILL BE OPERATING THE
SYSTEM INSTEAD OF THE AUTHORITY.
AND SO IN ESSENTIALLY WHAT
LOOKS TO BE LIKE A- LIKE A BIT
OF A SHELL GAME THE AUTHORITY
IS SAYING. WELL WE WON'T GET A
SUBSIDY TO THE AUTHORITY BUT
WILL GIVE A STATE SUBSIDY TO AN
EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR THAT THE
AUTHORITY CHOOSE IS THAT JUST
AS AN END RUN AROUND THE INTENT
OF. THE PROPOSITION DELAY NOTED
IN ITS REVIEW. OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN THIS IS
INCONSISTENT. ENTIRELY WITH
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY THREE TO
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. WILL
CLARIFY THAT NO MATTER WHO
OPERATES THE INITIAL OPERATING
SYSTEM. THE UTILIZATION OF ANY
STATE SUBSIDY VIOLATE PROP ONE
EIGHT AND IS THERE FOR ILLEGAL.
I THIS IS A TIMELY BILL WHICH
IS CRUCIAL BEFORE THE AUTHORITY
PROCEEDS WITH ITS TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLANNING BEGINS
SEEKING ADDITIONAL CONTRACTS.
HELEN CARE SYSTEM IS- WITH THIS
FROM THE LA- VIA PHONE TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION ON THE
LA DOES ANALYSIS. AND TWO OUT.
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
ABOUT COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO
WHICH- ONE ARE YOU THERE. HERE
YES PLEASE PROCEED. WONDERFUL
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE NUMBERS MY
NAME IS HELEN THIRTEEN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
DOING MARCH AND THIS YEAR OUR
OFFICE RELEASED A REPORT
REVIEWING THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITIES DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN IN THAT REPORT WE
MADE SEVERAL KEY OVERSIGHT
ISSUES FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER REGARDING THE PROJECT-
AND I DO HAVE TO SEPARATE THE
ISSUE THAT WE READ THAT THE
MOST RELEVANT THE BILL WHICH
RELATE THE AUTHORITIES
EXPECTATION THAT IT WILL
REQUIRE AN OPERATING SUBSIDY. I
TO SPECIFICALLY IN OUR REPORT
WE GET BACK HOW THE AUTHORITY
PLAN TO USE A THIRD PARTY
PUBLIC ENTITY OPERATE INTERN
SERVICE FROM MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD YOU CAN STILL TAKE
COMPLIANCE WITH PROPOSITION ONE
A APPEARS TO BE INCONSISTENT.
WITH THE SPIRIT OF THE MEASURE.
AB ONE A WRECK TO THAT PASSED
TRAINS. PROVIDED BY THE- NOT
REQUIRE AN OPERATING CITY IN A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT PLACES. IT
APPEARED TO ASK THAT THE GOAL
OF THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT
PASSENGERS OF THE SYSTEM RATHER
THAN THE GENERAL. I CORPS TAX.
A PAY FOR THE COST. OF THE
CONTINUED OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE PROJECT.
HOWEVER THAT FORTY PROPOSED
APPROACH- WOULD HAVE THE STATE
AND GENERAL GENERAL TAX PAYERS-
CAME FOR WHATEVER PORTION OF
THE- OPERATING COSTS ARE NOT
COVERED. YOUR I. EVEN THOUGH
THE IS NOT ANTICIPATED TO
RECEIVE AT THAT DRAW. UNDER
FORTY THE FRENCH IN THE- PLAN.
I DON'T KNOW REALLY CHANGE ON
FACT THAT STATE WOULD LIKE
THERE ARE OF THE SYSTEM DOCTOR
COSTS. AT LEAST DURING THAT AND
ON SERVICE THE OR SEVEN. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THROUGH THE MODERATORS ANYBODY
AND ON THE LINE FOR. THIS BILL.
REASON GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT AND
WISH TO HAVE LEAVE COMMENTS.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN MAY COMMENT
Q. JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THROUGH
THE MODERATORS NO COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BELL. WE
ACTUALLY WE DO HAVE ONE COMMENT
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT.
AND
NEXT WE'LL HEAR COMMENTS FROM
THE LINE OF KEEP IT DONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS KEEP DOWN ON THE ACTUALLY SO
STATION CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
TRAINS. I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION
DAY BE THIRTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
BUT ALSO FIRST ONE THE JUST
MAKE A COMMENT- AS WE TRIED TO
DIAL IN BUT HAD SOME DIFFICULTY
ON THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN THE READ
THIS BILL. AND I JUST WOULD SAY
THAT. THE NOTION OF MAKING THE
BEST INVESTMENTS FOR THE STATE
TO SUPPORT BY ALL OF US THIS IS
A PROGRAM I THINK THAT HAS HAD.
OVERSIGHT IN IN. DIRECTION
PROVIDED NOT ONLY BY THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIRMAN BUT- ASK GOVERNOR THE
CURRENT GOVERNOR AND IN MANY
OTHERS IN THAT. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE AUTHORITY HAD BEEN ON A
PATH OF MAKING THE BEST
DECISIONS POSSIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM AT THIS POINT SO I JUST
WOULD ADD THAT TO THE- THE SB
THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN- NOW FOR
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL- RESTRICTIONS.
I ON BEHALF TO SEARCHES FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED TRAIN TO
GET OPPOSE THIS BILL THE NOTION
THAT WE SHOULD PROHIBIT ANY AND
TO BE THAT HAVE ANY TYPES OF
SUBSIDY FROM. BEING ABLE TO
WORK AND PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM IS- IN DIRECT CONFLICT
WITH HOW WE OPERATE EVERY
SINGLE OTHER PROGRAM
TRANSPORTATION IN THE STATE.
THERE ARE SUBSIDIES PROGRAM
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM PRIVATE
ENTITIES THAT ALL BLEND
TOGETHER PROJECT. CLEAR OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WHETHER IT'S A
PRIVATE SECTOR. RAIL PROVIDED
THE MAY BE BUILDING A TRAIN
FROM NEVADA IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR SOME OTHER ENTITY
THAT MAY COMBINED THEIR
RESOURCES WITH THIS EFFORT
SHOULD NOT BE PROHIBITED I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE VOTERS
WANTED AND I THINK THAT THIS
BILL THE STEP IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. WITH THAT IS THE
MODERATOR HAVE ANYBODY. IN THE
QUEUE BUT AS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. WE HAVE COMMENTARY BY
JEREMY SMITH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- JENNY
**** YOUR BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION I
LIKE IT THANK YOU- AND EVERY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMING BACK TO WORK- THERE IN
THIS GREAT I KNOW OR AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE EFFORT
YOU'VE GONE YOU COULD BE HERE-
SPECIFICALLY ON THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT- I JUST WANTED
TO- REGISTER MY OPPOSITION AND
ADD THAT ELIMINATING EARLY
SERVICE OPERATION UP HI. GRETA
WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
OPERATIONAL I'M OPPORTUNITIES.
OUR ELIMINATE NEED THE KERR
PLAN HAVE YOU MADE FOR FILLED
IN WHITE. BILL THE RESULT
BECAUSE- NOW OF UNDER. JOBS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY TOLD.
CONNECTS IT MAY THIS ABOUT TIME.
TO ALL EVEN CERTAINTY TO
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. WHO ARE.
GETTING THE CROWD IN THE CITY
VALLEY. FOR THE JOB IN THE
COUNTRY INCENTIVIZE WE DON'T
WANT REDUCE THE OF CALLS JOB
MENTIONED ABOUT OR- DIFFERENCE
IN ABOUT PRESIDENT. IN
CALIFORNIA INTEREST. AND I LIKE
TO ADD ON TWO. A LOT TO
REGISTER MY UP AS OUR ACCOUNT
POSITION BILLS WELL I DID GET A
CHANCE. THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
FOR COMMENT IN THE OPPOSITION
KEEP. THANK YOU WITH THAT. ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE OF THE
AUTHOR. MR GIPSON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THIS ONE
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR WITH
THIS BILL INCREASED COSTS OF
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL INCREASE
COSTS FURTHER. HI ISRAEL. THANK
YOU MISTER GIVES APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION I REALLY DON'T THINK
SO WHY IS THAT- THE
CONSTRUCTION IS ONE THING. THE
OPERATION. AND THE SUBSIDY
NECESSARY TO CLOSE THAT GAP IS
AN OPERATIONAL QUESTION. AND I
THINK THAT THE BASIC. AB ONE
HERE WITH THE OPPOSITION IS
THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THE BOND
IS CLEAR. AND THAT THE BUSINESS
PLAN AS WE ARE LOOKING AT IT
NOW. SUGGESTS A AND RUN AROUND
THE EXPRESS LANGUAGE. IN THE
BOND MEASURE WHAT THIS DOES IS.
A LINE THE POLICY OF THE STATE
MAKING IT VERY VERY CLEAR THAT
THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
IS TO HAVE AN IMPACT SUPPORT
THE INTENT OF THE VOTERS. BUT
ALSO TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE LA-
HAS RAISED SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS AND THE BILL
ADDRESSES THOSE CONCERNS. I CAN
THANK YOU. YEAH OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR THE OFFER. THING NINE
MISTER PATTERSON WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU FOR- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS- FOR A
SUPPORTING AND MOVING IT
FORWARD APPRECIATE THAT BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS. IT IS THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS IT'S CLEARLY
ARTICULATED. IN THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BOND. THE PROBLEM THAT SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION HAS. IS WITH
THE CLARITY OF THE BOND
LANGUAGE AND THE EFFORTS OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY TO
SORT OF. AND RUN WHAT- THE
VOTERS INSISTED UPON WHEN THEY
APPROVED THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
LINE I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. I HAVE A FIRST
MINISTER PAUL. SECOND BY MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. MISTER PATTERSON
THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL. THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
INSTANCE WHICH THE AUTHORITY
HIGH SPEED RAIL THAT IS APPEARS
TO NEED CLARIFICATION FROM ITS
FUNDING PARTNER. WE CALL
OURSELVES LEGISLATURE. TO BE
CLEAR NO WE DID NOT MEAN TO
BAIT AND SWITCH THE VOTERS WITH
PROP ONE A- WE SAID NO. NO
OPERATING SUBSIDY AND WE MEANT
IT. EVEN THE PEER REVIEW
COMMITTEE HAS COME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION ON THIS ISSUE. AND
WITH THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER HI FONG FONG HI
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY NOT
VOTING BERMAN BERMAN HI TO TWO
HI CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI
DALY DALY I DEEP. DEEP I
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN UP VOTING
GIPSON. GIPSON HI GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HI KILEY. KILEY HI
MEDINA. MEDINA HI THERE IN.
THEY'RE IN NO O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL HI. TWELVE TWO TO
TWELVE TO ONE SIR. THE BILL
TWELVE ONE. MOVES OUT
GRADUATION THANK YOU FOR DOING
EVERYBODY PROJECT THE OPPORTUNE.
SO THERE'S NO NEED TO LIVE CALL
BECAUSE WE HAVE A FULL
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. HELLO FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART FOR BEING
HERE FOR MY BIRTHDAY BUT ALSO
UP FOR OUR FIRST MAYBE BACK
FROM LOCAL THE NINETEEN. AND I
APPRECIATION EVERYONE OF YOU
TAKING THE TIME AND SERVING THE
PEOPLE YOU REPRESENT. OF THIS
HEARING IS GOING TO BE
ADJOURNED TODAY. OF THAT JUST
WAS NOTIFIED TODAY OF THE LOSS
OF. ONE OF OUR THIRD HOUSE
MEMBERS TIM SHOCKED. YOU
REMEMBER HIM FROM. THE ART AND
ALSO- PMSA AND WHAT A WONDERFUL
MAN. AND TODAY WE'LL- ADJOURN.
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE ON
HIS BEHALF AND- MAY HE REST IN
PEACE WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED.